Anyway,
okay,
good,
good.
Let's go for it.
So,
jared,
you're going to bring us up to date.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
obviously a lot's been happening since,
um,
since we,
we last spoke on this issue and um,
to some extent I guess,
um,
what surprised me was not the amount of
lawyers and paralegals and licensees
that have not only reached out but
apparently written to the law society on
this statement of principles issue,
but more importantly,
the public.
I'm getting a lot of,
uh,
outreach from the general public and I
mean,
you can look at the,
uh,
the comments on the youtube video that
we put up.
The general public is concerned and they
are very much watching in terms of the
legal,
uh,
actors,
lawyers,
paralegals.
Um,
they,
I understand there are a lot that have
written,
um,
to the law society.
Uh,
the types of people that are reaching
out to me,
um,
are a broad cross section of the
industry,
a very experienced lawyers,
a very,
um,
well established lawyers.
Constitutional scholars are,
uh,
are doing their thing,
but I'm also getting paralegals who a
sense that there's a problem and they're
also writing.
One of the things that I think has been
interesting through all of this is that
the tone of the comments that I'm,
or the feedback I'm getting has migrated
in first instance.
It was a,
uh,
an issue with,
um,
okay.
Uh,
yes,
this compelled speech idea,
uh,
it sounds objectionable.
Those same people and some new people
are beginning to reach out and the,
and the commentary is changing to some
extent.
It is now that they're beginning to
examine the underlying report itself and
they're coming to me with questions
about,
well,
what does it mean that,
that the,
that there is systemic discrimination
and racism within the legal industry.
And what's interesting is I've actually
got racialized licensees that are big,
that are beginning to not only reach out
but also publicizing their opinions on
these things.
And,
and they're starting to grapple with
that larger question of,
well,
what does it mean when our industry is
systemically a discriminatory?
So people are becoming aware.
There's an awareness that's coming
about.
And I think a lot of that has to do
with,
with the media that's been coming out in
tandem with,
with what we did on,
on Youtube.
Yeah.
So the,
well in the problem with the systemic
racism charges that while it's vague and
that's for sure,
and then it targets everyone equally in
some sense within the profession and
requires systemic adjustment.
That's the other thing.
And obviously has to be supported with
hard data and it isn't self evident that
the data to support that claim is valid
by,
I would say,
by any stretch of the scientific
imagination.
So I've had a great deal of feedback as
well from,
from both lawyers and the
general public and they are of a mind,
uh,
I think as a jared described about their
concerns over the forced speech aspects
of this requirement.
I think we should make note of the kind
of response that has been generated from
supporters of this policy in response to
the kinds of concerns that have been
raised.
And a lot of those people who are
insisting that this is a legitimate
requirement are saying that although
it's called a statement,
it is not forced speech,
it's simply governance conduct.
And if I might,
I'll just read out a quote attributed to
the treasurer on this question that
appeared in the La Times.
Uh,
the treasurer was quoted as saying with
respect to the statement of values,
this is a conduct obligation to
recognize that we have to commit to
these values and it's not a speech
obligation or a thought obligation.
Now,
just on the face of it,
that statement seems strange to say the
least to say that when we have to do is
to commit.
And yet that's not either a thought
proposition or a speech proposition even
have to commit in a statement that
indicates that you have.
Right?
So it begs the question of what's the
definition of commit?
Correct?
Yes.
And the way that they're portraying it
is that this is simply a,
uh,
an articulation of the obligations that
lawyers already have in both the rules
of professional conduct and,
and in the human rights code,
which,
which is clearly not the case,
nowhere in the rules of professional
conduct or in the human rights code.
Is there any obligation upon anyone to
promote anything?
Well,
and also it's,
if,
if we,
if you already have that obligation and
why is it necessary to add this
additional layer of,
of,
let's call it obedience.
Yes.
Well,
let's just,
let's just note the,
the,
the two,
the two
contradictions in the portrayal of this.
On the one hand,
it is described as not a big deal.
Uh,
there are no immediate sanctions to
follow.
You don't have to send the statement in,
you just have to write it.
You just have to put it in your own
file.
So we're not worried about it.
It's,
it's,
it's no big thing.
Why are you so concerned about it?
And on the other hand,
they are emphasizing how central this is
to the project that they had set out.
And,
and,
and there are many people who have
suggested essentially that if you are
not willing to do this statement and
indicate your agreement with a certain
set of values,
then you should not be allowed to be a
lawyer and practice in Ontario.
Right?
Well,
that certainly seems to be the end game
and my sense has been watching this,
that because of the public pressure,
they're backing off to some degree in
their public statements by moving
forward into the future at some
indeterminate date,
the actual sanctions that will be
applied.
So that right now from a public
relations perspective,
it looks like this isn't a direct Konijn
a measure and we might as well also
remind people that,
and they might wonder why I am here.
Um,
my concern when I first encountered this
was that I know
I know what that sinking feeling you get
when you can predict the future
accurately and you don't like your
prediction that if the law society
prevails with this,
that the rest of the professional
organizations in Canada will follow in
lockstep very,
very rapidly and will end up in a
situation where every professional in
Canada is required to panda statement of
Principles that are essentially I'm
required by,
by their colleges espousing a particular
political and not only political but
philosophical and worldview philosophy
or risk losing their licenses.
And I mean,
I know in the legal,
in the law society already,
you have to.
There's a requirement that you have to
undertake training in relationship to
equity,
diversity and inclusivity,
right?
That's part of what they're requiring.
Well,
let's just read that out.
In this roster of recommendations,
that complication has passed his
recommendation and the third party
recommendation nine reads as follows,
the law society will require each
licensee to complete three hours of an
accredited program focused on equality
and inclusion with within the first
three years following the adoption of
the recommendations and one hour per
year.
They're every year thereafter,
which will count towards professionalism
hours for that year.
So in other words,
it is exactly as you've described,
Jordan,
uh,
there,
there will be training now so that you
have the right attitude about these
matters.
Right?
And I can just imagine what that
training will be like.
So.
Well,
there was some commentary in the
underlying report about unconscious bias
training.
And,
uh,
and I know,
Jordan,
that you've,
you've had some discussions about that
and some of your,
uh,
your public works.
Yeah.
Well,
there is absolutely no evidence
whatsoever that unconscious bias
training produces the results intended.
First of all,
the relationship between unconscious
bias,
say as assessed by the implicit
association test,
which is a pathological misuse of a
psychological instrument.
Even the people who designed it have
grudgingly admitted that there's a
relationship between those implicit
prejudice is so to speak,
which aren't even recognized universally
by psychologist as implicit prejudices.
The relationship between them in any
case in behavior is very,
very small.
It accounts for very overt behavior
and then the evidence that you can train
people out of those unconscious biases
is zero.
So this is,
this is a misuse of science and
education at,
at every level from a scientific
perspective.
It's the inappropriate politicization of
a very new line of inquiry in social
psychology.
And if the people who designed the IAT,
in my estimation had an ounce of,
of,
uh,
what would you say?
Intellectual Integrity,
they would denounce the misuse of their
test because it doesn't fit the
requirements that psychologists have
laid down for validity or reliability.
And that's partly why it's not
admissible in court,
for example.
Well,
the committees that are selecting our
judges currently are being put through
unconscious bias training.
And so,
uh,
question,
um,
whether or not the law society will,
will heed the warning that you just put
out there.
But yeah,
it's very unlikely,
and so you know,
I've already decided that with regards
to my clinical license,
if I was required to undertake this kind
of reeducation program and to pen a
statement of principles of that sort,
that I just give up my license.
So the way I'm doing that.
So the public,
that's the one thing I wanted to let you
know is that you're not alone,
Jordan.
The,
the,
the groundswell of public feedback that,
that I'm seeing and receiving directly
into my office has been significant.
People recognize exactly what we talked
about on the last video that,
that the legal industry and lawyers in
particular are supposed to be that bull
work against this type of overreach.
And so they really very much.
There's a,
there's a large segment of the
population that are worried.
They see that if the lawyers fall down,
then the rest will follow.
Can we just make a note of one argument
that has been made in favor of the
statement with kids that lawyers are
already subject to a set of ethical
obligations and this is just a one more
an extension of the same kind of idea,
but there is a significant difference
between the kind of ethical obligations
that exist,
which are essentially neutral non
political obligations that relate to the
way that our adversarial adjudication
system is supposed to work.
So it just,
for example,
every lawyer has an ethical obligation
to avoid a conflict of interest.
You can't represent both sides in a
dispute because that would be contrary
to the way our adversarial system that
is supposed to function.
That doesn't.
That doesn't make any sense.
You can't represent both sides in the
dispute,
but that ethical obligation doesn't have
political content.
It doesn't matter whether you are a
socialist or a conservative or a
classical liberal or anywhere on the
political spectrum.
The the.
If you are functioning in this legal
system,
it only makes logical sense that you
must proceed without in the absence of a
conflict of interest,
which is substantially different
proposition than the proposition that
these requirements are based on,
which are as,
as Jordan that you mentioned earlier,
these are politically charged and had
substantive political content in them
that they'd lost.
Society is essentially saying that
unless you adhere to a certain ideology
that you are not fit to practice law.
No.
It's also an admission that this is,
and this is,
I think the more,
perhaps even more dangerous element of
this is that to undertake reeducation
with regards to your political beliefs
surrounding or even factual beliefs
surrounding equity,
diversity and inclusivity is to act out
by implication the fact that you need
that reeducation because you're part of
the problem of systemic racism.
And you know,
it's very.
It's very psychologically significant to
act out in admission of your guilt.
Because what happens is generally
speaking,
is that people then retroactively alter
their self images and start to wonder
about such things.
You know,
because they're either powereds for,
for going along with the um,
uh,
with the requirements are liars for
producing a statement of principle that
they don't actually agree in or they
start to tilt their beliefs in the
direction that's required by the
demands.
And that's usually what happens.
And so,
and I'm quite convinced that the people
who do this sort of thing who make these
requirements know that and that it's a,
it's a manipulation on their part to
tell political belief overtly.
And so it,
you can't act these things out without
it having psychological consequences and
consequences.
Moral consequences,
let's say.
So it's very intrusive.
The other thing,
bruce,
it's important to remember is,
I mean the dichotomy between belief,
thought and conduct.
Currently lawyers in Ontario are subject
to the rules of professional conduct.
And,
and I,
uh,
right now we have an obligation to act
in a certain way and to refrain from
acting in other ways.
And one of the rules of professional
conduct is thou shall not discriminate.
And I don't think anybody would argue
with that and that thou shall act in
accordance with the,
with the human rights regime,
uh,
and,
and associated codes across Canada.
Nobody could argue with that.
But this statement of principles is
crossing the line into thought and
opinion.
And,
and one of the recommendations I would
note in the,
in the report,
recommendation number one,
they're actually proposing to review and
amend where appropriate,
the rules of professional conduct,
the paralegal rules of conduct and
commentaries to reinforce the
professional obligations of all
licensees to recognize,
acknowledge and promote principles of
equality,
diversity and inclusion.
Now I find that fascinating because
you're going to,
you're going to amend a rule of conduct
to,
to include of a sudden a,
uh,
an affirmation of thought while end and
to insist upon promotion as well,
which is,
why do you say very ill defined?
Yes.
So,
let's,
let's just go back to the words just to
make this point.
So again,
I'm going back through a,
um,
a quote attributed to the treasurer and
the La Times piece.
He says this,
uh,
the statement of values is an obligation
to promote equality,
diversity,
and inclusion generally,
which is nothing more than the
obligation lawyers have already,
but when you go to the rules of
professional conduct,
it says a lawyer has a special
responsibility to respect the
requirements of human rights laws in
force in Ontario and to honor the
obligation not to discriminate on the
grounds of race as a place of origin,
color,
etc. Etc.
That's Exactly as you just said,
jared.
This describes an obligation to observe
the law and this law consists of
prohibitions.
That is the obligation that lawyers are
under no doubt about it,
but they must do so,
but that does not include an obligation
to endorse and it does not include an
obligation to promote.
RighT,
and we should also point out just in
case it needs to be sad that none of the
three of us disagree with the idea that
people shouldn't be discriminated
against for reasons that have nothing to
do with their competence.
Agreed.
This is about is not what this was about
and it might also be useful to talk for
a moment.
Also about the word equality is equality
has two competing legal meanings and and
the law society has not defined which
one of them they mean explicitly,
but it's clear by implication which one
they mean,
and the two choices are formal equality
or substandard quality or quality of
results,
and the two things are quite different.
Formal equality simply means that the
same rules of conduct apply to everybody
regardless of background of of wealth,
of lineage,
of heritage,
and so on.
Same rules apply to everybody in the
same way.
Equality of result means that everybody
ends up in the same place and and note
that these two ideas of equality are
diametrically opposed and inconsistent
with each other because if you have
formal equality,
applying the same rules to everybody
because everybody is different,
you're going to have different results
for everybody.
If you insist upon the same results for
everybody.
That means you need different rules for
everybody for them to end up in the same
place,
so you cannot have both formally quality
and substandard quality together.
And traditionally the rule of law has
included the notion of formal equality.
If you have a properly functioning rule
of law,
that means you have the same rules
applying to everybody without regard to
who they are
with equality of outcome,
which is now often termed equity,
is you can group people,
each individual in a multitude of
different ways and it's impossible to
produce equality of outcome across all
those different dimensions of the
comparison,
so it's a never ending struggle to
produce equality of outcome.
It's technically impossible and and
societies that have tried that have had
a well,
it's been absolutely catastrophic and
terribly divisive.
It is also contrary to that fundamental
legal proposition that justice is blind.
Justice is supposed to be blind to all
of those personal certain
characteristics that one has,
whether it's race or color or gender or
wealth or background or lineage or or
or,
or political connection.
Whatever it happens to be,
a properly functioning judicial system
doesn't take account of who you are.
It simply takes account of the rules
that exist and tries to ensure that the
rules,
those rules are,
are,
are enforced equally in the same way
with an even hand against everybody.
And The so called,
well,
the data that has been generated is also
predicated on the implicit acceptance of
inequality of outcome,
a doctrine,
because the fact that every group isn't
equally represented at outcome is the
data point that's being used to indicate
systemic racism.
And so the,
uh,
so then you also think,
well,
what if you,
what if you're in a situation where as a
professional and an informed
professional,
you don't agree with the,
with the conclusions drawn from the data
set,
that there is indication of systemic
racism means is that now a belief that
you don't get to have?
Because if you are forced to write this
statement of principles and alter your
conduct,
then you're acting out the proposition
that you accept the conclusion that the
reason there are some differences in
representation across groups is because
the enterprise is the whole legal
enterprise is systemically racist and
they're buying.
You're also there by admitting your own
culpability in relationship to that and
the corruption of the entire legal
system.
It seems to me that you shouldn't be
required to admit to that if you don't
agree with it.
And that's the arc of the commentary,
as I mentioned at the outset,
is that it started in one place and the
feedback I'm getting now is very much in
that place that people are beginning to
question,
okay,
what does it mean,
uh,
the findings of this report for me
personally and for my industry?
And,
and what does the data say?
And people are digging down on it.
In fact,
I just read an article the other day
that said that there's actually been a
doubling in the representation of
racialized licensees within the
industry,
uh,
between 2011 and 2014.
Um,
you know,
that's not something I think a lot of
people recognize is that,
yes,
well,
the report may may have touched on
something in terms of findings.
Um,
there's also,
uh,
some things to celebrate.
The other thing too is that you have to
specify it in a report like that.
If you're going to consider this
something approximating a scientific
investigation which you and it wasn't
conducted in a manner that would meet
those requirements,
in my estimation,
that there's going to be a lag in ethnic
representation as the population
demographics change because the
demographics of the population from
immigration are going to change more
rapidly than the the than a than a
representation of people in the
professions just because of the
necessity for the new immigrants to take
time to be incorporated into the culture
and so the real point of data should
have been the rate at which new comers
are being integrated into the profession
rather than the absolute numbers of
people who are there already and that's
self evident and so the fact that that
isn't being considered deeply in the in
the data is also indicative in my
opinion,
of the political slapped of the
interpretative framework through which
the data was analyzed.
We'll make noTe of the irony of the way
that the word diversity is being used
and the means by which are being used to
promote diversity.
because in a sense,
I'm the objectives of these
recommendations is the opposite of
diversity,
real diversity,
genuine deep diversity is diverse,
includes diversity of thought,
diversity of opinion,
diversity of worldview,
diversity of ideology,
including all the other issues of
diversity and diversity is a very,
very important thing for a pluralistic
society.
You don't have diversity in a
pluralistic society,
then you,
you must be living under some kind of
tyranny because everybody is different
and everybody deserves to be allowed to
be different than to think different
things and to behave in different ways
as long as they don't encroach upon the
rights of other people.
But,
um,
but the,
the vision that seems to ally underneath
these provisions is a very singular one,
a vision that everybody will think and,
and adopt progressive values that a
proper law firm consists of a group of
progressively thinking lawyers,
uh,
that,
that looked like a rainbow,
um,
as opposed to.
So there's,
there's an appalling proposition
underneath that tooth.
It's actually factually incorrect.
So the fundamental racist proposition is
that racial groups differ sufficiently
so that you can identify them as
separate entities and that they should
be treated in that manner,
but the data suggests very strongly that
even in situations where men and women,
different temperament,
um,
on average,
that the overlap between men and women
is larger than the differences and the
differences within the groups.
So the differences between women and the
differences between men within their own
groups are larger than the differences
between and women.
So you don't get true diversity by
selecting across groups that isn't how
it works.
In fact,
that's actually a fundamentally racist
or sexist claim right down to the core.
And to predicate to assume that what you
get is diversity of opinion by selecting
for diversity,
let's say,
of race is.
Well,
first of all it's wrong.
It's just technically incorrect.
And second,
I don't see how that's distinguishable
from the claims of the jim crow type.
So the 19 fifties who said,
well,
you know,
black people and white people are so
different that they should remain
segregated.
It's like they're not that different.
so,
and,
but within the groups,
they're very different,
but between the groups,
they're not that much different.
The differences aren't,
aren't like the differences between men
and women aren't nonexistent,
but even then you wouldn't select on the
basis of those differences to produce
diversity of opinion.
So yeah,
but it's not the diversity of thought
model that,
that organizations are including our own
governments are pursuing at this point,
the philosophy side.
He's not alone in that,
in assuming that,
that people who all think alike but that
have different racial or gender
backgrounds,
um,
is in fact diversity.
I mean the ontario securities commission
has been mandating that type of
diversity on,
on boards of directors for publicly
traded companies.
Um,
you know,
the,
the federal government in its cabinet
appointments is pursuing that,
that type of diversity that really is
not a diversity of thought,
so to speak or opinion.
But a diversity of,
of,
um,
well in,
in the federal government's case,
gendered.
Yeah.
Well,
the other thing that's going to happen
is that if we,
you know,
the people who hold the political views
that are pushing these ideas forward are
convinced beyond,
um,
beyond argument that what they're going
to do is to what the instantiation of
these policies is going to result in is
increased racial harmony and let's say
harmony between the sexes,
but I think you could make a very strong
case for exactly the opposite,
which is the more that we define people
by race and gender,
the more that people are going to be
defined by race and gender.
And I don't see that at all.
I Really don't see that as a recipe for
social harmony.
I don't think it's worked in the United
States at all.
Quite the contrary.
And we actually have a pretty harmonious
society already by,
by any reasonable standard,
any reasonable world standard.
And I think that this will inflame
tensions between groups unnecessarily.
Well,
I actually had a,
a lawyer reach out to me,
a racialized licensee and say exactly
that,
that their main concern with what they
were seeing,
not only in the compelled speech
component on the statement of values,
but also the underlying recommendations
of the report is he thought that that
was going to inflame tensions or
animosity towards people in his group.
And,
and I,
I had never thought of it that way,
but he was quite concerned that this was
actually to,
to generate anamis against those that
actually sought to protect.
So that's,
that's one viewpoint that I hadn't,
hadn't expected.
So should we are discussed for a moment
on the emotion that is being brought to
complication.
A joe [inaudible] who is a lawyer in an
adventure,
uh,
has,
put together a motion to change the
nature of the statement of values
requirement.
And perhaps I'll just read out the key
provision of this motion,
moved that convocation,
approve that no licensee who has a
conscientious objection to the adoption
of a statement of principles shall be
required to comply with recommendations.
And they shall be exempted from the
requirements of recommendation three,
one to adopt and abide by a statement of
principles.
Now I'm joe is a fellow that has my
utmost respect.
Uh,
he's,
uh,
he's done a great deal of good inside
complication,
I think as,
as a venture.
And I admire his willingness to put
forward this motion,
which means he's sticking his head up
from a crowd that doesn't really want to
stick their heads up.
Absolutely.
But nevertheless,
they're there.
There are some difficulties with the
emotion.
Jared,
do you want to speak to that first?
Well,
yeah.
So,
uh,
the motion itself,
somebody was talking to me about it and
they said the problem is,
is that,
um,
it makes it appear that if one elects
not to file the statement of values.
So if you,
if the motion is passed and they,
they then decide I'm not going to file
the statement of values on that basis
that you would be seen or it would be
interpreted as you being a conscientious
objector to the values that the law
society statement of values is,
is asking us to affirm.
And,
and it rather than an objection to this
idea of compelled speech or being forced
to disclose or divulge what may be in
your head or what your thoughts and
opinions may be,
and I,
and I hadn't thought of it that way,
but when you look at the motion,
yes,
it very much can be interpreted that
way.
Right?
And so in essence,
it does not save you from having to,
uh,
to,
to perform the forced speech obligation.
Just use you another thing to indicate
which essentially requires you to stick
your head up and be counted one way or
the other.
In other words,
the law society is still succeeding at
dividing people between those people who
are willing to do the statement and
those people who refuse to do it,
but have to say that they refused to do
it.
So there is still forced speech in here,
even if the motion passes.
Yeah,
I don't think it gets us to where we
need to be.
Um,
you know,
and as you said,
I think joe's,
uh,
joe's a tremendous person deserves a lot
of respect.
He's fighting his own free speech
battles before,
before the supreme court of Canada in
early november.
Um,
as you may know,
he,
he was,
uh,
accused of crossing some imaginary line
about the conduct of his defense.
I'm a of an individual before the courts
and,
and that is a very novel idea.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
the industry is watching with some
interest to see what the supreme court
of Canada says about whether or not
there is a line in the sand as to the
type of advocacy can pursue.
So he is,
uh,
joe is somebody to watch and someone
respected.
But I think the emotion comes up
slightly short of where it needs to be.
I don't think it gets us to the plAce
that I think we need to be,
which is that the law society should not
be mad meddling or even asking what the,
uh,
what the thoughts in and conscience is
of its members.
Right?
So As of right now,
there is nothing on the table that as
far as we are,
we're concerned that vex offers the
possibility of,
of eliminating the objectionable aspect
of this forced speech obligation on
flooding.
Know iT's interesting.
Go ahead Jordan.
Okay.
Well,
we'd also talked a little bit about the
fact that,
you know,
we had concentrated specifically on the
statement of principles as the
objectionable element of the
recommendations,
but the recommendations as a package or
also objectionable because they're all
fed by the same underlying philosophy
of,
of well systemic racism,
let's say,
and,
and the promotion of equity,
diversity,
and,
and equality as the highest of,
of,
of moral values.
So do we want to talk a little bit about
the rest of the recommendation?
Sure.
Yeah.
Let's.
Well,
let's,
uh,
I'll,
I'll read out the first one.
Perhaps the first one,
uh,
gives a flavor for the whole,
the whole host of them.
So the first one goes like this.
The law society will review and amend
where appropriate the rules of
professional conduct and the paralegal
rules of conduct and commentaries to
reinforce the professional obligations
of all licensees to recognize,
acknowledge,
and promote principles of equality,
diversity and inclusion,
consistent with the requirements under
human rights legislation and this
special responsibilities of licensees in
the legal imperiled legal profession.
Now,
um,
the,
there are those words,
again,
we talked on.
You also mean if you abide by that,
that you have to accept the definition
of diversity as essentially predicated
both on race and sex.
Uh,
yeah.
Well,
of course they haven't defined
diversity,
but consistent with the rest of the
regime.
Yes.
That,
that,
that in the way that we have previously
described that that is the meaning of
diversity that they're going for.
And also the meaning of equality as I
suggested earlier.
Right.
So,
um,
the,
and of course there's their internal
contradictions in the statement because
they're going to amend the rules of
professional conduct.
So as to reinforce obligations that
don't exist,
would they really mean to say is we're
going to change them so as to create new
obligations.
The,
um,
requirements under human rights
legislation that this recommendation
refers to act again,
do not include the obligation to
acknowledge and promote.
They are,
they are conduct laws that everybody is
subject to,
but they prohibit certain things.
So,
um,
so like the statement,
uh,
this first recommendation that gives the
flavor of all the rest of them,
uh,
suggests that the law society is
essentially moving into a new area,
an area of regulating competence.
And if I can put it this way,
instead of being a,
a neutral regulator of competence in the
political sentence,
uh,
they have now more or less taken on the
mandate of regulating competence in,
in the political sense,
in the ideological sense.
They are essentially saying,
here are some values that regulator is
going to require you to comply with
these values.
Essentially our progressive values.
So in the digital or not a progressive
lawyer,
we do not think that you have the right
to practice law in this province
and as the only values that are going to
be the subject of a statement of values.
they are elevating those,
uh,
to a position of prominence.
Uh,
and I would suggest beyond all others,
yes,
sure.
The,
these,
these values because of their,
of their listed in a special way.
It seemed to be put above other more
fundamental values like the rule of law,
like formal equality,
like competence or like,
like,
well,
competence you would think would be the
core mandate of the law society itself.
And my competence,
I mean skills,
knowledge and compliance with ethics,
professionalism,
professional.
This also seems to be to be reflective
of a constant push on the part of
political ideologues,
of the progressive type
to mandate that have all the rights that
canadians enjoy or perhaps the
obligations they have to undertake,
that the rights of the rights that are
associated with equality,
diversity and inclusivity are going to
be made paramount in relationship to all
of the other rights.
And that seems to me to be an utter
catastrophe.
So.
well,
the proponents of the,
uh,
of the statement of values,
the people that I've seen writing
commentary pieces,
none of them seem to disagree that there
is a compelled speech component inherent
in the statement of values.
What they do is they say,
okay,
but under section one of the charter and
an oaks test analysis that infringement
on freedom of conscience,
freedom of thought,
freedom of expression is reasonable to
attain the objective of equality,
which is also a competing right under
the charter.
And inevitably,
and I think they have a point,
a,
anytime the supreme court of Canada has
engaged in a section one analysis on
freedom of speech,
uh,
that,
that butts up against the competing
equality,
right?
They tend to find that save and except
for the most egregious infringements
that the equality rights shall prevail
or be the,
the tipping factor.
And so it's like I said,
it's interesting that the proponents,
they don't disagree.
Oh yeah,
we're putting a compelled speech
component on you,
but it's a very effective.
Also note this though,
because the first part of section 15 it,
is it really a section about formal
equality vii,
the equal application of laws to
everybody.
What does not the,
the quality of their talking about.
So they,
they are,
they aren't shifting the ground on what
equality means and then staying and that
content kind of equality justified the
infringement of these,
of these other rights under section one,
as you say.
So do you want to continue bruce?
With.
So,
so let me,
let me read
another one.
Um,
let me just find it here.
Uh,
I want to read the one.
Here we go.
This is recommendation 10.
This is,
I want to read this one because it just
reinforces the proposition that we spoke
about which is at the law society is,
is changing the nature of competence to
encompass a certain set of political
values.
So they're doing this explicitly.
Recommendation 10 says as follows,
the law society will include the topics
of cultural competency,
equality and inclusion in the
professions as competencies to be
acquired in the license,
the process.
So if you are along a young lawyer,
a young law school,
graduate,
and you were applying to be licensed by
the law society,
these are among the things that you must
show to them that you are competent in,
that you,
you,
you believe and agree and follow.
These particular values,
it'll be on the bar exam.
Yes.
Yeah.
Shelly,
continue on.
There's the uh,
there's the same.
Uh,
I believe I read out already is the
requirement for the continuing education
matter.
Let,
let's move to one of the recommendations
that are being put in place this year.
The statement of values is,
is one on the and the other one that is
mandatory for work legal workplaces have
over a 10 lawyers goes like this.
The law society will require a,
a licensee representative of each legal
workplace of at least 10 licensees in
ontario to develop,
implement and maintain a human rights
diversity policy or their legal
workforce addressing at the very least
fair recruitment,
retention and advancement which will be
available to members of the profession
and the public upon request.
So,
so there,
there's a measurement issue because
measurement,
an enforcement issue.
So the measurement issue is well what is
fair and how is it defined?
So is it defined by the racial makeup of
the firm over the next 10 years?
So if it doesn't shift in the required
direction,
let's say,
or the gender makeup of the firm,
it doesn't shift in the required
direction.
Does that mean you're out of compliance,
like the details in this sort of the
measurement details and this sort of
thing really matter who defines fair and
then what's enforced and who's going to
like it are,
are the firm's going to be subject to an
external analysis that examines their,
their diversity makeup over some period
of time?
And is there,
is there going to be provisions about
how rapidly the,
the,
uh,
the ethnic and sex makeup of the firm
has to transform across time?
Like the devil's in the details in this
sort of thing.
They're proposing actually that a,
that a member of the workplace conduct,
uh,
an inclusion self-assessment every,
every two years to get at the measuring
component.
And so what's an inclusion
self-assessment mean?
Exactly.
What do you think that means?
Does that mean what do you do?
Do you lift list your race mean or do
you,
do you,
do you examine your soul to determine
whether you're,
you're oriented in the proper inclusive
in this direction in relationship to
race and gender?
Like I don't understand.
I don't because I'm a measurement guy.
Fundamentally,
you know,
I don't understand how these things are
going to be assessed.
They are not easy to assess.
And then there's the enforcement
problem.
I,
I really don't know what the word
inclusion means.
I have ideas about what a quality can
mean.
I have ideas about what diversity can
I don't know what inclusion means.
I,
I really just don't understand the word.
I don't know how you measure it.
I don't know what you mean by that.
The law society has been collecting data
for four years.
Uh,
I'm on these types of demographics on
the basis of a,
a voluntary survey basis.
Um,
and so what they've,
they're actually proposing to go further
is that within these legal workplaces
that these workplaces conduct inclusion
surveys now,
there was a tremendous amount of
conversation at the convocation meeting
that adopted these recommendations about
compelling people to self identify
within some sort of demographic group or
the other and that there would be some,
there's,
there would be some risk resistance,
particularly among racialized licensees
of doing so,
so they're going to make it voluntary,
but that then goes to the issue of
what's the quality of the data that
they're getting,
Jordan,
if it's a voluntary self reporting
exercise and not everybody's reporting
because as they said at convocation,
some groups may be,
uh,
disinclined or fearful of,
of identifying themselves for whatever
reason,
what's the quality of the data they're
getting,
and then how are they going to act on
that data?
Yeah.
Or maybe even unwilling to identify
themselves.
Well,
that's what I told you.
I don't see why,
why it's free.
It should be required of me that I
reveal my what,
what,
which aspects of my identity,
what am I going to reveal?
So I mean obviously I'm white,
whatever the hell that means,
so,
but there's all sorts of other aspects
of my identity that for,
for example,
I might want to keep private
even the existing data on which they
founded a,
the finding of systemic discrimination.
The empirical data was based on
voluntary survey data.
So we're not even certain that we're
getting what I would say is his
confidence send census type quality
data.
So I read you another one of these
recommendations,
a recommendation 12,
two,
it says that the law society will revise
the rules of professional conduct and
the paralegal rules of conduct where
appropriate so that the discrimination
is clearly identified as a breach of
professional conduct requirements.
So say that.
Say that again.
Yes,
I,
I will.
The law society will revise the rules of
professional conduct where appropriate
so that systemic discrimination is
clearly identified as a breach of
professional conduct requirements.
Okay.
So that means that at some point in the
future could be assessed for its
compliance with equality.
However,
that's defined perhaps as equality of
outcome,
but we don't know.
Or with regards to rate of
transformation of demographic
membership,
and if you're found not to be in
compliance,
whatever that means,
then that means that you've.
You've engaged in proFessional
misconduct.
Yes,
but it's interesting that they used the
word systemic discrimination because
that meant we're talking,
we've used that term in the past to talk
about the profession and that's the way
they use that term in the report that
the profession has a problem of systemic
discrimination,
so I'm just puzzling over the use of
that term in this particular
recommendation because it suggests that
if you are or your firm is,
is guilty of systemic discrimination,
then that is a matter of reaching your
conduct obligation.
What does that.
Does that mean that every single lawyer
in the firm is guilty of that because
that's what systemic would imply.
It also begs the question of how many
people you need to be systemically
racist before you actually have a
system?
Well,
they're going to be doing a benchmarking
exercise.
I mean,
that's part of it is that you're going
to have to submit these inclusion
assessments to the law society and then
they're actually going to review that as
against the industry as a whole,
uh,
in terms of finding out where you're at
on your inclusivity.
And so my concern would that they find
systemic discrimination within an
organization because it falls short of,
of what the industry writes wide
standard is in terms of it's um,
well,
it's diversity a layup
date.
Right?
And so what that'll mean fundamentally,
it's,
let's say that you have a firm that has,
that it's a small firm,
say 10 people and all of the people in
it happened to be caucasian just for the
sake of argument.
So that mean that you'll be mandated to
hire by race for the next while.
Well,
your systemics,
you're just,
you're systemically discriminatory
organization.
I think.
Let's,
do you mandated to do that?
How is that legal?
How is that possibly illegal to be
mandated to hire by race
only by virtue of the mandate that the
law society has from the government to
regulate the,
the legal professional.
I mean that,
that,
that what it has to rest on,
if,
if you read the statutory mandate of the
law society,
it would seem to fall outside the
marching orders and the law society has
at least as it is simply worded.
The prompts I can read you that this is,
this is a,
a section 41 of the law society act.
Uh,
sorry.
Let me read first,
section four,
point one.
This is the function of the law society
is to ensure that all persons who
practiced law in ontario or provide
legal services in ontario meet standards
of learning professional competence and
professional conduct that are
appropriate for the legal services they
provide.
So unless you can fit this into the
phrase professional conduct then then
under this section there is no mandate
to do these kinds of things.
I was going to read section 41 which
lists a the standards of professional
competence that the law society supposed
to ensure.
And section 41 says a licensee fails to
meet standards of professional
competence for the purpose of this act.
If,
and there are a number of things listed,
but the ones that are relevant here are
a,
if there are deficiencies in the
licensees knowledge,
skill or judgment or the licensees
attention to the interests of clients,
and those are the only two bits of that
section that applied to this question
and they don't apply.
They don't destroy drive the nature of
these obligations that are being
contemplated.
Can you zoom?
If I was applying for a job at a law
firm that was a compelled by this
mandate to diverse itself,
diversify itself racially and I was a
qualified candidate and I got wind of
the fact that that requirement had been
put in place,
couldn't I go after the firm for
discrimination because they made race a,
one of the basis of hiring that they
were compelled to make race one of the
basis of hiring
the,
uh,
the human rights code and the charter of
rights and freedoms allow for certain
forms of discrimination when it's,
uh,
when it's for the purposes of an amelia
amelia exercise.
Um,
for instance,
if there is systemic discrimination
identified,
the charter will permit discrimination
against a group in order to remedy what
it may be perceived as a systemic
discrimination issue.
This,
I mean specifically addresses and
exempts,
uh,
affirmative action type programs as,
as being found to be discriminatory and
allows them,
it permits them.
So the answer would be yes,
you could raise that,
um,
but the but the law firm and the law
society,
if they would have to then bring forward
evidence that this is part of a,
a,
you know,
an affirmative action type program that
is exempted and I'll let you,
you're allowed to discriminate on that
basis.
We,
for a moment just turned to one of the
justifications that have been given for
this whole slate of recommendations.
This whole program which is that your,
your membership in the law society is a
voluntary thing.
You don't have to belong to the law
society.
This is not the state coming down and
requiring all its citizens to do a
certain thing.
You have chosen to be a member of the
law society and therefore you must take
these obligations on voluntarily.
Which of course is a ridiculous thing to
say because the law society takes its
mandate from the government.
The government has,
has given the law society of the job,
of being the gatekeeper,
um,
of,
of the,
of the rights to practice law.
And if you are to practice law in this
province,
you,
you must be a member and you must adhere
to the rules of conduct that they,
that they require you to suggest that,
that your at your,
uh,
your engagement with the law society is
something that you do a voluntarily just
because you wish to do so.
And that makeS it a voluntary
organization.
It is in a.
Right?
So the voluntary aspect is that you can
give up your heart one livelihood if you
don't want to be subject to these rules.
Yes.
So I suppose you could make a case that
that's voluntary,
but I mean it's certainly the case that
it stretches.
It certainly stretches the definition of
what normal people would consider
volunteering.
Well,
it,
it turns,
it turns the idea that you would have a,
you would have a right to practice in
any profession if you have the proper
skill and training and competence to do
so.
That question is,
is up for grabs now because they're
essentially saying,
well actually what you also have to do
is go along with our vision the way
things are supposed to be and the way
you think.
And if you don't choose to go along with
that way,
well then you're free to go off and do
something else
and what other people's values migrate
over time.
So it is right now,
you know,
these,
these values that we're looking at in
the statement of principles here.
But what if they migrate over time,
what could they become?
You know,
and I think it sets a precedent that,
that we might want to push back against
swelled it,
it's worrisome because the values are
very ill defined.
And so an ill dEfined like a box that
could contain anything ends up
containing a very strange number of
things.
And you know,
bruce pointed that out very clearly when
he talked about his inability to
understand what constitutes inclusivity.
It's like,
okay,
so let's say that we could,
we could define equality and diversity
if we were willing to even using racial
and gender categories,
which I think is a unbelievably
catastrophic error.
But okay.
Inclusivity.
Well if that's definition list,
then it's a place to put any other
requirements that might come along.
I don't know.
I really can't say what it.
What does inclusivity mean?
Is that more like the nonverbal behavior
that you might manifest,
you know,
or,
or is it,
does it refer to more subtle
interactions within the firm?
That's kinda what it sounds like.
So yeah.
So at least it might be worthwhile
trying to find out what they mean by
inclusivity.
No.
If they really want to be inclusive,
they would get rid of the bar admission
exams.
They would get rid of the loss of law
school record underlying requirements.
I mean that's essentially makes your
organization inclusive,
doesn't it?
When you get rid of the barriers to
entry
fish and too is that if you went and
analyzed the uh,
the success rate at with regards to the
bar exam,
that you'd find that it produced
systemic discrimination as well because
the probability that that an objective
test produces exactly the same results
across all conceivable groups is zero.
So,
and you know,
you see this sort of thing happening in
the United States already where
competency requirements produce group
differences,
especially if you analyze enough group
differences.
and so what happens then is the
competency requirements are
gerrymandered to eliminate the group
differences.
So,
and that's all part of an assault,
I would say on the idea of objective
competence.
so
book are there,
are there more,
are there more statements that are worth
analyzing?
Well,
let's just have a look here.
I mean there's a,
there's a whole a whole roster of them,
but I think those are the ones that are
most pressing.
Um,
well,
well I thought there was,
there was
an interesting one.
It was,
it was recommendation 12 sub for they
want,
they want to create a specialized and
trained team to address complaints of
discrimination.
Now,
I mean,
I don't argue that,
I mean discrimination in any act of
discrimination that is a contravention
of,
of human rights legislation should be
stamped out.
It should be,
it should be identified and dealt with.
But my understanding is that we've got
the bodies that are responsible for
already not only the spirit court,
but also the,
uh,
the human rights tribunals.
So I,
I wonder what that,
I mean I read that and I say that that's
a swat team.
There's a swat team that's going to
swoop in on the noncompliant,
systemically discriminatory
organizations and sort them out that,
that concerns me to some extent,
particularly,
like I said,
because we have this,
we have these bodies already in place
that are supposed to deal with these
types of things.
They're doing
get bodies.
So you have the classic court system
plus the ontario human rights tribunals
which already have their own problems.
So the word in that recommendation,
that consciously real concern is the
word address.
This,
this team will address complaints of
discrimination.
Now that doesn't say whether or not they
are the investigator or whether they are
the adjudicator or whether or not
they're a combination of the two,
whether or not they are judge,
jury and executioner all rolled into
one.
I would be much more comfortable if they
were procedurally precise to say exactly
what the function of this so called team
was supposed to be.
But what's,
I mean,
what's it for?
We've got a human rights commission that
can come into any organization and
workplace in ontario without a warrant,
uh,
and do this,
whatever it is these,
this,
this group wants to do.
So I,
I questioned creating another layer of
bureaucracy.
But.
Well,
I agree,
I agree.
But what I mean,
one of the needs for this might be
because of the point that we made
earlier,
which is that the requirements of the
law society is now creating our,
are not the same as they are under the
human rights code.
Right?
So the human rights commission and
tribunal might not have jurisdiction
because that's not what the access.
And if,
if these do we create extra and
additional requirements that are not
now,
um,
uh,
the doe now apply to lawyers,
then you do need an extra bureaucracy
to,
to enforce them because nobody else has
the jurisdiction to do so.
Right?
And then you can pursue,
I think without any fearing error that
the people who would constitute such a
team would be the ones who would be most
zealously in favor of precisely this
kind of progressive,
let's call it.
You would expect.
Oh yes,
definitely.
That,
that's how it works.
Well,
if they're in favor of compelled speech
and think that that's justified,
then I would question what other
fundamental rights and freedoms they,
they might a dean to stamp stamp upon.
Alright.
So maybe we should move from dance.
one of the things we discussed was
perhaps asking for more public
involvement in our campaign,
let's say.
Um,
and so I believe that we're going to
provide contact information for the
benchers,
is that correct?
And asked members of the public to
listen very carefully to the discussions
that we've had and to indicate to the
benchers their concern about this in
terms of its relationship to the broader
public potential relationship to the
broader public sat,
the law society is,
is his mandate is to,
is to govern the profession,
but within the,
I guess the best interest of the public
to protect the public.
And so the public very much as a
stakeholder in what's happening right
now within the legal industry and the
law society.
And so absolutely I would encourage the
public to,
to make any concerns that they may have
known,
um,
and right to the people that make these
decisions and let them know their
thoughts because this is,
this is something like this was a,
a public trust in this industry to some
extent.
And so the public,
very much it hasn't.
It should be vested in what's happening.
Yeah.
Well,
it's a fundamental public trust because
it,
it deals with the,
the underlying structure of the legal
system.
And so it,
this is partly why this is so worrisome
to me because I know perfectly well that
if,
if the lawyers fold on this and the law
society succeeds in pushing forward
these requirements and then,
and then enforcing them across time,
that every professional organization in
Canada is going to follow suit.
And after that,
well,
once the professional organizations
follow suit,
then there's no,
there's no reason to assume that this
isn't going to spread more widely.
So the,
the,
the main justification underlying all of
this that the law society is relying on
is the public interest.
So if,
if the public doesn't think this
reflects their interest,
they had better say so.
And the licensees obviously a,
anything they can do to reach out,
I think is,
uh,
is some assistance.
I think the current motion that's before
the law society is to a great extent,
a byproduct of that groundswell of
support or opposition,
I guess you'd say.
I'm from lawyers and paralegals.
And if they can direct those efforts and
continue them,
I think it can be of some assistance.
Hmm.
Alright.
So we broadened the scope of what we
regard as worthy of opposition,
partly because the attempts,
let's say so far to ameliorate the worst
elements of the policies that are being
promoted are insufficient for the task
and even if they were put into place
like the motion that you described it
would be a victory at 10 percent or
something like that.
And,
and not,
not move the underlying,
um,
pathological principals in my estimation
far enough.
It's something like that.
It wouldn't eradicate the threat that
we've been trying to warn people about.
correct.
That's right there.
There is no immediate prospect right now
of,
of getting rid of the forced speech
element of this policy and the other
elements are consistent with that,
that requirement and are being carried
along.
And,
and although only three of the
recommendations are being put in place
immediately,
the rest will follow into a course and
there's no reason to think that they
won't be done aggressively.
And uh,
and was forced.
Alright.
Well I guess,
do you guys have anything else to say?
I mean,
maybe thank you to the people who've
already been paying attention and
well,
let's,
let's just thank the people who have
gone ahead already and,
and contacted their benchers contact
with the law society to,
to register their objection to ask
questions.
A lot of people have done a very good
things on and,
and our thinking well about this.
They,
they're thinking intelligently.
They're thinking broadly.
They the lie.
My hat's off to them.
There are a great number of people who,
who are very clear about this and some
are reticent to make too much of a fuss.
Some are quite happy to say what they
think and I respect both of those
positions.
Um,
but,
but I guess the message overall is there
are a great many people who think this
and the,
that the worst outcome would be that
nobody acts upon what they think.
And this just sort of happens without us
noticing.
I've been heartened by the but by what I
see to be singular acts of courage in
the people that have taken action
written to the law society and even just
reaching out to,
to my office and to others.
It's not easy to do.
And,
and I,
you know,
I support and,
and commend those that are doing that
and people have written,
people have written articles and blog
posts.
There are some really excellent pieces
of work on this topic and perhaps we
could even refer,
um,
uh,
provide links to some of those sources.
But,
but,
uh,
they're really worth a read a reading.
They're very well done,
very thoughtful pieces and they have a
ring of truth to them
from all over to them from outside.
I've seen things from outside the
jurisdiction.
I'll,
I think New Zealand,
there's a great,
great blog by a professor at university
of auckland in New Zealand who's written
on this.
It's,
it's,
it's well worth the read.
Yeah.
Well,
these things do have international
significance because my observation has
been that if one major jurisdiction or
organization in the west moves forward
in this hypothetically progressive
direction,
the probability that it will spread
because of rapid electronic
communication and pretty decent
organization on the part of the people
who do push these things forward,
that it,
that it emerges everywhere with
extraordinary,
extraordinary rapidity.
So anyone who shares the basIc axioms of
our legal system is,
is involved in this whether they like it
or not.
Right.
All right,
well I guess we'll see what happens
and maybe will provide an update again
in a couple of weeks.